la rénovation énergétique ne concerne
pas que les acheteurs et les vendeurs
cette professionnelle sur saint quentin
en yvelines ont signé jeudi 23 septembre
actimos un programme d'accompagnement
des acteurs de l'immobilier qui a une
une réforme du dpe au 1er juillet 2021
donc du coup de nouvelles normes de
calcul un nouveau document qui était
dite et aider les clients se posent des
questions de savoir quelles sont les
implications donc on peut leur expliquer
ce qui se passe dans la réglementation
on se confond de plus en plus à des gens
qui nous qui justement sont surtout ski
évolution énergétique et nous en tant
que banque on n'a pas forcément les
solutions entre nos mains et se
rapprocher d'un partenaire local qu'est
avec les sky du coup c'est toujours
intéressant une signature réalisé avec
l' agence locale de l'énergie et du
climat de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
lauréats depuis février 2020 de ce
projet porté par leclerc réseau pour la
transition énergétique d'avoir ces
professionnels finalement du logement de
l'habitat qui s'engagent à nos côtés ça
nous permet de toucher un public
peut-être un peu plus large et puis
surtout de prodiguer des conseils en
amont avant même de passer à une phase
qui est plutôt des phases de travaux de
réhabilitation là on agit en amont sur
la question de la transition énergétique
le programme sera accompagné de
formation et de sensibilisation pour
tous les signataires de nombreuses aides
à la rénovation sont disponibles à ma
prime rennes-om habiter mieux série
n'était ou encore éco prêt